welcome to this video playing for its
car frequent opponent decent score okay
I get this one again sometimes play this
line as well okay well that's that's
quite comfortable for black already from
here so we three can even go d 5 in this
position rocky come on go t 6 it's not
really any issue here
so care of this hmm okay what is there I
don't let's let's play a game quite
often in those kind of systems white
players just dash out stuff and they
just want to get some kind of
development and don't really have any
particular d by d em and sometimes you
just try to figure it out and while you
do so you do is on time so i just
decided to speed up and it paid off what
is this white noise I ok I was quick so
we can do a quick opening recap that out
of that of that short game yeah so
before age six an ideas be five in this
position trying to make this look bad I
probably go to 85 him and it's not a
great piece them but ok this is not a
mistake or anything here here writes you
for mp5 at all it's normal I did this is
a bit a bit surprising but it's still
nothing much going on Bishop c5 maybe
normal normal moves yeah this is just a
blunder okay well thanks for watching